we begin with a major milestone for  johnson and johnson's vaccine candidate  the fda just gave it approval this  morning so we can tell you health  officials  say it is 66 percent effective overall  and more than 80 percent effective at  preventing severe coven 19. johnson and  johnson's vaccine only requires  one shot and the fda said that will  definitely help speed up the vaccination  process so now we will have three  coveted vaccine options so some good  news with that let's take a look at our  latest coven numbers  our state positivity rate continues to  drop today now sits around  9 percent that's some also good news  statewide we've had more than 292  thousand cases since the pandemic  started  over 4 900 people have died this is in  the past year  now most of those cases statewide are  from here clark county  that amounts to just over 225 thousand  over 3 800 people have died  the good news about 96 percent of all  cases  have recovered